okay I need to talk to you about
something really important today and I
need some time to lay this all out for
you but hopefully it'll be productive
yesterday I started getting emails and
seeing comments saying David will you
disclose your funding and will you
disclose whether you're getting money
from a pro Bashar al-asad group that is
in existence to prop up the Syrian
regime disclose your funding and tell us
who your funders are and it seemed like
a weird thing to ask of me I didn't
understand why are people coming to me
and saying am i getting funding from a
from a probe Bashar al-asad group so I
started researching this and then I saw
a couple of reports and posts that there
are several left-wing independent media
people that have allegedly received
money from a pro-assad group some under
the guise of a journalism award money
that was awarded for winning a
journalism prize so I want to do this
and I'm gonna give you the full
breakdown of our revenue at the end of
the segment but let's go through this
and actually try to do it right so let's
begin with what are the allegations the
allegations are that several left-wing
independent media hosts and writers and
publications received money from a group
called the Association for investment in
popular action committees it's a very
sort of innocuous name but investigative
reporting by Charles David claims to
demonstrate that this is actually an
umbrella organization that is covering
for and the sort of a name placeholder
for a groups that are Pro Syrian
dictator Bashar al-assad the Association
for investment in popular action
committees has a trademark called the
serious solidarity movement which again
it sounds Pro rights but it's its
pro-assad and the idea here is that this
is an umbrella group for pro Syrian
government organizations when you look
at them on guidestar it's very innocuous
it's a civil rights advocacy group
organized in 2007 there's limited
information it's headed up by two guys
Paul LaRue Dee and Kamal obeyed and when
I started looking into this and this is
all new to me I've you know I did did
the research over the last 24 hours
obaid has said that he
a member of architects and engineers for
9/11 truth which is a 9/11 truther group
I would call it a conspiracy group so
it's starting to get a little bit weird
and the revelations that have come
forward for independent media are that
this group has created something called
the Serena shim Award for uncompromised
integrity and journalism which Awards
money to different media people they've
paid former Ohio Democratic governor
Dennis Kucinich $20,000 to speak at a
pro Bashar al-asad conference in the
United Kingdom and it so happened that
Kucinich opted not to condemn Assad a
few years ago and it turns out that some
people including former TYT host jimmy
dore door a I don't know how the name is
pronounced now as well as youtuber Kim
Iverson who I didn't know much about and
many others have received money from
this group through this award now let's
go through it there are some trends that
exist here both door and Iverson have
done a combination of questioning the
known facts about Bashar al-assad and
have started to dabble in some
conspiratorial false-flag stuff as well
both door and Iverson have put out
content that is very Pro tulsi gabbard
and Tulsi has her own sort of history
with Assad that has been a subject of
scrutiny there is an IRS filing which
you can easily find online from the
pro-assad group which shows that in 2017
door received twenty five hundred
dollars from this group while Kim
Iverson previously posted to Instagram
that she received five thousand dollars
from the group so the first question is
can we trust the allegation in other
words did these people and the others
that are listed in the piece that we're
linking to did they receive this money
Iverson admits she got the money she
posted about it and unless the IRS
filings are false door did as well
there's a longer list of people you can
find online but did part one did they
get the money it appears that they did
so then we have to ask well even if it's
a pro-assad group that is funding the
award are they is is are they getting
money to say certain thing
or are they merely being awarded for the
things that they're already choosing to
say and I think that this is an
important distinction with a lot we've
talked about this before you know that
it's common that people at Fox News
people at RT Russian television they'll
say nobody ever comes in and tells me
exactly what I need to say and of course
it doesn't work that way it's not say
this stuff and then we will pay you it
is often that people are selected for
roles on the basis of what they're
already likely to say so we really don't
know the reality of this that's one
thing then there's this issue you know
it it correlates with the pro tulsi
stuff and alternative facts around Syria
and related topics this is odd but
ultimately it's their business now if it
were me I would disclose this stuff
full-stop I mean I don't I don't have
any other way that I would qualify it I
would just disclose it so then we come
to me and the emails I've been getting
over the last 14 16 hours saying David
you're part of this disclose your
funding we want to know where you get
your money so I'm gonna do that first of
all I don't know why anyone would think
I'm getting money from a pro-assad group
or pro-assad sources particularly ones
that are peddling and you know we're
their leaders the disobeyed guy pedals
in 9/11 truth or stuff or anything I
don't do any of what they do you know I
I don't do Assad apologetics I don't do
Pro tulsi apologetics I don't do any of
this stuff but I'll just come clean and
tell you our funding this is from a
normal month this is data from August
the but we it's the beginning of October
so I haven't closed the books on
September yet but this is a typical
month this is August we got 40% of our
revenue from memberships patreon and
apparel 32 and a half percent from
YouTube ads 22% from ad sales three and
a half percent from twitch as many of
you know we're new to twitch so that's a
pretty small part of our revenue right
now Facebook ads we're now monetizing on
Facebook but only about 1% of our
revenue and miscellaneous donations are
0.1% now those miscellaneous donations
of course could come from anybody but
what I'm talking about is sometimes
people don't want a membership they'll
just send us you know a check for a
little bit of money and that was 0.1% of
our funding back in August we don't take
money from any groups if we have an
advertiser it
Martha's an advertisement if we do a
sponsored video its marked as a
sponsored video that's it so I can't
speak to the strategy behind other
people's actions I have no idea what
people's financial situations are and
what would cause them to accept or not
accept money from an organization like
this everybody's financial situations
are different and also I don't know if
what people are concerned about is that
the the content of these programs is
influenced by the fact that they've
received money from this group or if
people are concerned about the lack of
disclosure or something else and it
would be interesting to clarify that but
to be very clear
people are often chosen for awards
because they're saying the right things
and of course the award can be a way to
funnel money to someone under the guise
of we are rewarding you for good
reporting or whatever the case may be
but typically that's not how it works
people people are brought in or
supported because they're already saying
the things that the funder wants them to
say so that's our funding I can't speak
for anybody else and I hope that this
will sort of put to bed the questions
I've been getting over the last half day
or so